How did three petty criminals launch a
business empire, land a Guinness World Record,
and become hallucinations of themselves? It
all started in a little place called Sunnyvale.
While it may appear that the show's central
trailer park has always looked the same,
the first four seasons of Trailer Park Boys were
filmed at different locations across Nova Scotia,
Canada. Due to complaints by the residents,
the boys were supposedly forced out of
these parks and eventually opted to
purchase and build their own set in
Dartmouth. This is the park which fans
started seeing from season 5 onwards.
"It's a terrible situation."
Of course, the spin-off series, Out of the
Park, sees the characters Ricky, Julian,
and Bubbles going on adventures, making stops
in Europe and the United States. But while the
trio have gone international, the true home
of the Boys is their eponymous trailer park.
There's been plenty of speculation surrounding
the departure of Jonathan Torrens' J-Roc from
the show. Torrens announced his
departure via Twitter on April 20,
2016, and later said in his
podcast, Taggart and Torrens,
"I ultimately felt that I had
achieved all that I could with J-Roc,
but he's been in my head and part of
my existence for so long, it's weird."
Although fans would love to see their favorite
rapper drop more bars at park concerts,
Torrens insists gave the role everything he had.
The show's theme song is tranquil and gives
fans a peaceful view of the park before the
F-bombs and complete comedic chaos takes
over. It was directly influenced by singer
Tony Bennett's signature song, "I Left
My Heart in San Francisco," which peaked
at No. 19 on the Billboard Hot 100 when
originally released in 1962. And in 2001,
the tune peaked at No. 1 in the hearts
of Trailer Park Boys fans when "I Left
My Heart in San Francisco" was adapted by
Blain Morris into the theme song "Breeze."
Although fans probably prefer calling it
simply the Trailer Park Boys Theme Song,
from Bennett to Morris, the song
has and will always be a classic.
While it can be more rewarding to watch a
continuous, overarching story from start
to finish — since audiences get to see
character development, minor story arcs,
and the plot pay off — Trailer Park
Boys is meant to be episodic. People
should be able to watch any episode
and still understand what's happening.
"If you guys come back short, you're gonna
be responsible. Do you understand me?"
"I'm not stupid, Julian."
"Yes, you are stupid. That's
why I have to tell you this."
There are running jokes that any diehard
fan will appreciate, such as Randy's "shirt
allergy," but a first-time viewer should be able
to watch any episode and understand the plot.
But episodic or not, watching the
show in chronological order allows
viewers to better understand
the characters. On the surface,
the Boys are just criminals who routinely
come up with small-minded plans,
break laws and wind up in jail. But as episodes
build on one another, Ricky, Julian, Bubbles,
and the rest of the park residents become
more charismatic, redeemable, and root-worthy.
Jimmy Buffett has Margaritaville, Mark
Wahlberg has Wahlburgers, and Bubbles had
Bubbles Mansion. Unfortunately, they had to
close their doors in 2010. According to CBC,
manager Brad Hartlin said the Halifax bar
could no longer compete because students
stopped coming once legislation forced
minimum drink prices up from $1 to $2.50.
Although eight Liquor Control Act violations
had also hit their other bar, The Toothy Moose,
Hartlin claimed the closing of
Bubbles Mansion wasn't related
to these legal troubles. No matter the
reasoning, Trailer Park Boys was — and
still is — famous enough for their
characters to open a bar in their name.
The characters Jim and Barbara Lahey had
a daughter named Treena. Though she didn't
make many appearances throughout the series, they
might recognize her now famous actor: Elliot Page.
While Page has gone on to star in major Hollywood
projects like Juno, Inception, and The Umbrella
Academy, he walked onto the Trailer Park Boys set
as an unknown and left as a beloved character.
"Would you be upset if your mom and Sam broke up?"
"Would Randy be upset if you
gave him a double cheeseburger?"
Treena would visit Mr. Lahey in the
summers and befriended Ricky despite
her father telling her to stay away from him
and Julian. While Page only appeared in a few
episodes in Season 2, Treena is mentioned
affectionately throughout the series.
John Dunsworth — who played the fan-favorite
character Jim Lahey — passed away from an
unexpected illness at 71 years old in 2017.
His daughter, Sarah Dunsworth-Nickerson – who
also plays the character of Sarah on
the show – announced the sad news of
her father's passing via Twitter on
October 16, 2017. The tweet read,
"With heavy and broken hearts the family
of John F. Dunsworth would like to let
people know that our amazing husband,
father and John Dunsworth has passed
away. John left this world peacefully
after a short and unexpected illness."
After Dunsworth's death, the Season
12 finale concluded with a heartfelt
tribute to Dunsworth as well as
some eerie words from Mr. Lahey,
"When you're dead, you're dead. But you're not
quite so dead if you contribute something."
In the first episode of Trailer
Park Boys: The Animated Series,
Mr. Lahey is carried off by a hawk,
which is probably the perfect ending
to a character who's always been
dropping isms related to hawks.
Donny, the neighbor who's always screaming
off-camera at the boys, might sound familiar.
That's because the character is the voice
of Mike Smith. While Donny might appear
to unleash a whole lot of unnecessary rip-roaring
monologues, he sometimes does it for good reason.
"Donny, watch your language!
There are children in this park."
Instead of being a wordless bystander, Donny
takes direct action by yelling uncontrollably
at loud noises — such as crashing cars and
gunshots. We've all got a breaking point,
and sometimes a person just wants peace and quiet.
While Donny is finally seen on-camera in
Season 12 his face is blurred out. His voice,
which could use a bar of soap or
two, is still performed by Smith.
While Julian always wears the same outfit of
a black shirt and blue jeans — usually while
holding a rum and coke — Ricky wearing the
same exact shirt throughout each season is
to a different effect, even ending up
ripped or duct-taped in some seasons.
While Ricky does change his clothes the running
joke is that he has an extremely limited number
of shirts. Usually using one shirt per
season keeps this joke rolling, and the
wear and tear give his wardrobe that authentic,
Ricky-really-only-does-have-a-few-shirts feel..
It may be hard today to believe Trailer
Park Boys originally ended after seven
seasons. When Netflix took over in 2014,
they added five more seasons — as well
as specials, an animated series,
and multiple feature-length films.
The Netflix deal came on the
heels of Wells, Tremblay,
and Smith acquiring the rights to the show
from original producers Mike Clattenburg,
Barrie Dunn, and Mike Volpe. In
a statement, Clattenburg claimed,
"While the three of us have moved on to different
TV and film projects, the Boys are the only ones
with the intimate knowledge and love of the
show to keep Trailer Park Boys alive and well."
Not only has Netflix helped bring new life to TPB,
but they have brought the show
to a vastly wider audience.
SwearNet — created by Wells, Tremblay, and Smith
— features the entire world of Trailer Park Boys,
and has become a true business empire,
creating its own beer, whiskey, and much more.
"He said he was really impressed with the customer
service, and the beer's going great,
man. People are f—ing loving it!"
"Yeah!"
"And he wants more."
The website features clips of the Trailer
Park Boys family doing what they do best,
as well as clips capturing Wells,
Tremblay, and Smith out of character. Plus,
it even has its own movie — titled
Swearnet: The Movie — which holds
the current Guinness World Record for the
most uses of the F-word in movie history.
Creating an animated spinoff of a pre-existing,
live-action television series is nothing new.
Star Trek, and the Canadian comedy Corner
Gas turned to cartoons to tell stories that
would have been difficult with their
flesh-and-blood actors. To this end,
in 2019, Trailer Park Boys: The Animated
Series debuted on Netflix as a direct
follow-up to the original series, which
had just completed its 12th season.
According to The Cord, the franchise going
animated was an in-universe plot development
choice. At the end of Season 12, a gaggle of
characters were arrested for participating
in a drug smuggling operation, right after
they collectively consumed pounds of magic
mushrooms. As the hallucinogenic
effects of those mushrooms kick in,
the characters start to see themselves
and their world as a giant cartoon.
Additionally, transitioning to an animated format
allowed the production to address the death of
John Dunsworth. The producers opted to initially
keep Mr. Lahey alive in the animated series,
constructing his dialogue from old voice lines
recorded for episodes of the live-action series.
Trailer Park Boys was one of those early
series which helped pioneer the mockumentary
format in comedic television. Well before The
Office, Modern Family, or Abbott Elementary,
the Canadian series aimed to produce a seemingly
realistic look at life of petty criminals in a
trailer park community. The characters were
acutely aware of the cameras in their faces
and would comment on how they were being
filmed for a documentary. According to The
Globe and Mail — to keep this idea going
— the three main stars of the show rarely
appear in public or give interviews
out of character or out of costume.
"I'm Bubbles."
"I'm Julian."
"Am I…? I'm Ricky, but my passport says Randy
Lahey, so I'm not really sure who I am."
Smith, Wells, and Tremblay have received awards,
appeared on talk shows, and performed live as
their Trailer Park Boys personas. They refuse
to break character in behind-the-scenes footage
available as DVD extras, and in 2019, the trio
set sail on a Trailer Park Boys-themed cruise,
playing their roles for five straight
days while mingling with fans.
The titular trailer park trio
might be petty ne'er-do-wells,
but offscreen, the franchise's
actors and creative forces have
used their popularity and influence to
push for social and legislative change.
In May 2021, Wells, Smith, and Tremblay starred
in a 50-second public service announcement for
Nova Scotia's department of health, titled Part of
Our Way Forward, where they advocate for getting
the COVID-19 vaccination. In March 2022, the
Boys produced and posted to Twitter a video
to bring awareness to the issue of poor quality
drinking water in indigenous Canadian communities,
"Government, just fix the indigenous water
problem would ya? It's not that hard."
"Please."
"Fix it, please!"
According to HuffPost, back in 2016, the Nova
Scotia government did away with a tax credit
that encouraged films and TV shows to shoot
in the province. Since the TPB production
was a beneficiary of that program, the Boys
waged the #SaveSunnyvale campaign on social
media in protest. Smith made a video, as Bubbles,
warning audiences that their show could possibly
end without these financial advantages, and
days later, a $10 million production fund was
established. Reportedly, $810,000 of this fund
went to fund Season 10 of Trailer Park Boys.
The show's Canadian pride is often reflected
in the music used throughout the franchise — a
lot of the needle drops go to some
of Canada's most successful acts,
such as Rush, the Tragically Hip, and
April Wine. Some Canadian music legends
have even physically appeared
on Trailer Park Boys projects.
"Randy cheated and stole his answer."
"That's right, Alex. I'm
a way bigger fan than him.
You're the best guitar player that ever lived."
Per the CBC, in 2003, the primary
trio served as an opening act on a
package tour with Canadian bands Finger
Eleven and Our Lady Peace. And in 2017,
Quebec-based EDM artist Marc Mysterio remixed
Bubbles' signature folk tune. Mike Smith has
also popped up as Bubbles in videos by rap-reggae
artist Snow and rock band The Tragically Hip.
According to Sleaze Roxx, in 2019, the Boys staged
a full-length concert at the Hair in the Fair
Festival in Welland, Ontario, assisted by Canadian
hair metal figure Sebastian Bach of Skid Row. This
wasn't too surprising as Bach has appeared as
himself on multiple Trailer Park Boys projects.
Trailer Park Boys isn't just a single show,
evolving through several formats with new
methods. After seven seasons on Canada's Showcase
network, the feature films Countdown to Liquor Day
and Don't Legalize It were produced and then
released in Canadian movie theaters in 2009
and 2014 respectively, bridging the original
show with the Netflix series revival in 2014.
After 50 more episodes on the streaming
service, Trailer Park Boys evolved into two
seasons' worth of the animated series, and then
returned to live-action with Trailer Park Boys:
Jail. Distributed by SwearNet, the 2021
series of 10 episodes finds the criminally
mischievous Ricky, Julian, and Bubbles in
a familiar place — prison. But this time,
it's a semi-permanent situation. While the trio
usually don't leave the Sunnyvale Trailer Park,
they're prohibited from leaving the
Sunnyvale Correctional Facility,
where it's considerably harder for them
to get up to their usual shenanigans.